- What's going on everybody?
my name is Sylvan LaCue
from Miami, Florida.
Wise, wise, wise.
And you are now listening to
the Monday to Monday playlist,
from my man Gary Vee and my boy.
- How are you man?
- Good to see you.
- It's good to see you.
- You well?
- I'm fantastic, alright.
- Good, man.
- Absolutely.
- Yo.
(mumbling)
- Jonathan
- Jonathan, how are you man?
- Amir.
- Good to see you, man.
- Good to see you.
- How you been?
- Good, how about yourself?
- I've been well.
I have been well.
It's ugly out there, huh?
- Yeah.
(mumbling)
- It's special outside.
- [Gary] It is special outside.
- It's definitely war,
you know what I mean?
(laughing)
- [Gary] A different form.
- But yeah, so they're in town.
He leaves tomorrow.
He just did a sold out show in LA,
sold out show in New York.
- How was it?
- [Amir] Fantastic.
- Definitely one of those moments that
had to culminate, rare
culmination to like that place.
Lot of hard work, just really
grateful, taking it all in.
- How long were the shows.
- I believe New York show's
about an hour and 15 for my set,
so overall two hours.
Same thing for LA as well,
maybe a little bit longer in LA.
Had a little bit more lead time.
So it was great, man.
- Good for you, man.
- I think we jump right into it.
But one thing that's so interesting,
the reason why this meeting's
so important is like,
he has this song Empathy,
Gratitude, Selfish,
but I think so in line
with what Gary says about
you gotta cut out your loser friend
or you gotta, you gotta be selfish.
- To be selfless.
- You struggle with that.
You have struggled.
So where are you at right now?
- I mean, I still, it's still
something I struggle with.
I don't think you ever completely
stop having those moments, right?
Because you know, you're a caring person.
So you genuinely are gonna go through it
from time after time.
I think it's just become cognitive
of it and conscious of it
so that you can see when it's happening.
So I've gotten a lot better at it
just in terms of taking time for myself
and making sure that I can fill my cup.
But I don't think it's
something that ever goes away.
You just become conscious
of it and do better at it
step by step by step.
- When it's your demeanor, right?
Either you're giving energy
or you're taking energy.
So I've been thinking,
it's actually really funny
we're having this conversation,
I thought about it a lot this morning
when I was working out
on the way into work,
it's like my natural default is to give.
It's why good has happened.
But there's always a breaking point.
You know?
- Mm hmm.
- And there's a couple different
relationships right now
where I'm just like fuck,
they're about to walk into a buzzsaw,
'cause I haven't given
them any indication,
that's the one thing I
wanna do a better job of.
I feel like I,
I don't wanna just default
into I'm a good person,
and then just,
one of the things I'm
most embarrassed of ever
is when I was a teenager
and my early twenties,
the way I would break up with a girl
was so disrespectful and not,
just genuinely not a man about it.
I would just disappear.
It was easy with no technology.
(laughing)
But, but, but, at the same token,
it would have meant that I would have been
absolutely that person that just
everything was great for nine months
and then I would just
text and be like I'm out.
So I don't judge people period,
because I think it's a bad idea,
but I think the thing that I'm constantly,
even at 42 I'm like,
I've gotta do a better job,
I'm doing a way better,
I'm not anywhere close to that version,
but more indicators along the way of
this isn't or cool or this isn't right.
- Yeah.
- So that it's not just
like fuck you this is over.
What is that?
Pigs get fat, hogs get slaughtered.
Or something.
My natural demeanor is to give so much
that the other person doesn't even realize
that they're becoming a hog.
- Yeah, I can understand that too because,
especially from the value
that you place on that.
It's like when you're giving
and giving and giving,
in your mind it's like,
this is what I'm outputting,
this is what my energy is for.
And rightfully so, you do it
from the bottom of your heart,
so it doesn't matter what happens,
where the relationship stands,
when you're giving something
it's genuinely because you want to.
And at the same time, when
something or certain situations
are happening, you're
like this isn't cool.
And for me I've been one of those guys
where sometimes I just internalize things,
and then when I'm ready, I'm ready.
And I don't realize that
nobody else has been prepared.
It's kind of like a blindside.
- Yeah, it's an emotional strength
that, you know, your gift is your curse.
Listen I wouldn't trade it for anything.
I wouldn't trade it for anything.
But I wanna be more conscious of it,
because even from VaynerMedia
as an 850 person company,
18 months ago I woke up, I'm like,
my company's entitled.
I'm thinking about my kids, I'm like,
they're gonna be entitled.
Emotionally.
It's emotional.
You know?
And that's it.
My family breaks if my mom or I
are not in a good mood for a minute.
One minute.
One minute at a dinner
table of like, not cool,
and everyone's like.
Even when I did Planet of the Apps,
my energy was so high and awesome,
and there was some stuff going down
that I wasn't pumped with.
And I was like this next pitch
I'm just gonna shut down,
and the whole, everyone
was like what the fuck.
- How do you deal with
that type of burden?
Knowing that there's--
- I'm grateful, first of
all, 'cause it's power.
Nobody has leverage over me.
I prefer it.
It's the leverage.
So the burden now becomes more of like,
even in your full right,
don't have a macro,
to me, I'm never gonna
feel bad about blindsiding,
like, you're fired.
"What the fuck?"
Or like, yo, I don't wanna work
with you like that anymore,
or you know what, you're asking too,
people ask, ask, ask, ask, ask,
and then it's finally
like you know what, nah.
Now what?
What are you gonna do about it?
'Cause I've got leverage.
What I think I'm doing with it
is just trying to be more conscious.
I don't wanna sandbag people.
There's a fine line between,
look everybody's a big boy and girl,
and you expect people to,
when you internalize it,
what we're talking about right now,
what you're doing is you're
hoping the other person
recognizes how good it is, and
what value they're getting,
and why do they keep
asking for more inches.
So I don't feel bad for the
person that's taking too much
and hasn't figured out how to do it.
I just wanna be the best
version of myself that I can be.
(laughing)
Right?
- Sounds very familiar.
(laughing)
- So that's it.
That's kinda how I think about it.
- Got ya.
(laughing)
(mumbling)
But I wanted to, how
did you guys meet, man?
How did this start?
We all know who you are, Amir.
(mumbling) managers in the game, bro.
- I appreciate that.
I'm honestly, I'm grateful
for that for real.
Man, long story, like
the long story short,
we actually met at SXSW, we got introduced
by a gentleman by the
name of Mike Shahade,
but I don't remember
because unfortunately--
- [Gary] That's just that world.
- Well it was actually a melee,
ASAP mob was fighting,
and I had (mumbling) DMs.
(laughing)
God rest is soul.
And so my fatherly leader instinct
was to run to see what's going on,
but then fast forward a year later,
he was coming to do some
content with Alt-F Digital.
And he killed it, we met,
probably, it wasn't on the shoot,
but we met right after the shoot.
And then he just was, I don't know,
he's just considerate, he's
kind, I like the music.
He wasn't on the Apologies Advanced,
you hadn't worked on any
of those records yet.
We just kept in touch.
He came back to do another
piece of content with us
and crushed it, crushing it for real.
And I found out he actually came down from
Oakland to LA on a bus.
And I was pissed at my
team 'cause I was like
yo, you could have just flown him, right.
But you came in the same day?
- Yeah, I came in that day, took a bus,
then knew I could be around those artists,
and then a took bus right back.
- Yeah, and then a couple months later,
he was like I wanna sit
down, didn't even ask
for me to manage him, but
we just kinda hit it off
and I saw something
there, and then I had to
do one more thing on my checklist,
which was to see him perform.
I saw him perform, it was like he put his
own headliner tour together
called the Loner Tour.
December 2016?
- Yeah.
- And then after that
it was like official.
- It's funny, the bus
story is super interesting.
I've been thinking a lot
about humility and hunger.
I like putting letters together.
(laughing)
The passion and patience
thing really worked for me.
That's just real humility and real hunger.
It really works.
- He was hungry, I could
see it in his face.
- People are hungry and fancy.
- Yeah, that's right.
No, no, that's right.
He wasn't.
- You know and people
are humble and passive.
But if you have humility and hunger.
- He definitely had it.
I mean afterwards I thought about it
I was like wow this guy's
going back to Oakland,
and he'd just come from Oakland on a bus.
I would have thought his
performance would have been, eh.
- Sure.
- This is after the fact.
I was like yo, he killed it.
Who are you?
And that's how I felt.
I felt something.
- [Gary] Talent.
- Yeah, talent.
- [Gary] It's talent.
When you have real talent,
if it's parented right, if
the environment's right,
I think real talent comes,
I think humility naturally
comes with talent.
I really do.
I think are people confused.
I think it's the reverse
of what people think.
Because if you have talent,
and you're self aware about it,
you actually are humbled
by it and more importantly,
you feel like whether it's inevitable or,
you're just patient with it.
I watch people say it's
just a matter of time
and it's fake bravado.
I see it every day.
Just a matter of time,
every day on social especially.
Just a matter of time
before I, but it's fake.
And then I see the version
of just the matter of time,
and it's taking a bus.
I'll do anything still.
What I really like about humility
is it's the core to longevity.
Because you never, I will
never go to that other spot.
I'm just gonna stay in this lane.
I hear and see everything
that's happening with me,
I just almost weirdly don't accept it.
You know?
I'm unable to,
and the people closest to
me, like my assistants,
Babin or Drock, there's always something
that I do that I can
see through their eyes
them saying, "Why's he doing that?"
- It's funny you say that.
Because I've been trying
to pinpoint that emotion
for a very, very long time.
Probably like the last
six to seven months.
Because things have been--
- [Gary] Happening.
- Happening, you know, repeatedly.
And I think when we sold out Los Angeles,
which was our first time every
selling out a show in Los Angeles,
we've done tons and tons of shows.
- And how many people?
- It was 300.
- Go ahead.
- I've been in that
position where I'm opening
for artists at that level
on a consistent basis.
So when that was happening
and everybody's celebrating,
obviously I'm taking this moment in,
but there's always that part
of me that's just like...
- There's a big delta between
300 and Madison Square Garden.
- Yeah.
- For me too.
I get it, man.
- But it's also this very,
you feel so grateful
for something happening,
that it's almost like you don't
want it to get to your head.
- It's humility and hunger, man.
You got the humility to be
like, "Wow, this is amazing,"
but you're hungry and thinking,
"You know what's better than 300?
"30,000."
To me, and listen man,
it's gonna get more and more intense.
Where I'm sitting right now in my life,
culturally, financially,
impact, it's very high.
I know where I'm at.
And man, I don't feel
any different than I did
the first day I did a
flea market when I was 14.
It's crazy.
It's almost like something
is keeping me in a bubble
outside of all the admiration and success.
I don't know what else to tell you.
It's humility and hunger.
I'm humbled by it, I
don't take it for granted.
I don't think I'm special.
I think it's part of the output.
I think my parents are special,
I think my circumstance was special.
And I'm just still so hungry.
You know?
- Yeah, stay hungry.
- That's wild.
- And I think if that's foundational,
I think I don't know who they are,
but somebody won four
Grammys and did a show
two days earlier to 81,000, and felt
the same way I feel right
now or you feel right now.
You know?
I don't know.
- That's a good point to make,
come to that type of emotion.
- Yeah, if it's there, it's there.
I don't know.
There's nothing I've seen,
I've never been like,
you made it, or I'm always
like humility, I'm like cool.
Nightline or a cover of a magazine or
somebody cool DMs me.
I'm like yeah, I'm like this is cool.
- [Amir] This is dope, but
still, there's something else.
- There's never been anything like--
- I also think what's great about that
is because it's also rooted in love.
So love doesn't really have a price.
So it doesn't matter what is you do.
You can attain 20,000 buildings and
sell out as many concerts
and win 85 Grammys
and be respected by your peers,
and do all the coolest
things in the world,
but the love of what you're
doing is immeasurable.
There's no price tag to it.
- [Gary] And it's also unlimited.
- Yes, definitely.
- So I think that's the thing for me.
It's unlimited.
There is, it's not even,
to your point of measurability,
there is no finish line.
I mean, for me it's impact.
There is no, like what?
I'm not to gonna get
to 7.8 billion people.
The pope doesn't do that.
Jesus Christ doesn't do that.
Mohammad Ali didn't do that.
Gandhi didn't do that.
Martin Luther King didn't.
You're not gonna get to everybody.
So to me it's almost
like, well let me try.
(laughing)
Meaning, and again, it's
about self awareness.
Right now I'm laughing,
'cause I know that's on film
and people are gonna
watch that and be like,
"This guy's fucking,
the ego is unbearable."
I think people are confused.
It's the reverse.
If you live your life in a way like that,
it's not that I expect
to be on that pedestal,
or to be very frank, or even want that.
It's why not bring that much good?
- [Sylvan] Yeah, that's right.
- To me, why not?
What's the collateral of that ambition?
'Cause that's my life.
My life is gonna be the
collateral of the ambition
to make that kind of impact
and have that kind of legacy.
That's what my day to day is.
And what's really interesting for me
is unlike you and others,
I didn't grow up doing
something that made me think,
or aspiring to do something
that made me think
I could have that kind of impact.
That's the great misunderstanding
of this amazing time,
is I, pre-internet, would
have been a good business man,
affected the 1,000 to 5,000
people that worked with me,
and probably just 87 to 92 that
worked close enough with me.
My family, my kids, and
I woulda called it a day.
Because I didn't do music or politics or
write novels or poetry.
I wasn't doing art.
Which is how you actually get there.
But I feel like how I build businesses
and things of that nature is that.
It just, we didn't live
in a world where that was,
as a matter of fact, I've
been spending a lot of time
looking at entrepreneurs in the 1800s.
They made so much of the
good impact in our society.
In the days of kings and early
countries being established,
it's funny, I've always
not liked the narrative
of bussinesses have a responsibility.
Meaning not how the Republicans
or Democrats looked at it,
some of it was too bullshit
and just for the money,
and others were too
altruistic and not practical.
But I have been trying
to find that middle zone
of what's happening with me and now.
Spending a lot of time on it.
But it's really cool to
think about this conversation
in a macro, meaning something's
clearly happening where
the level of conversation is just
going in the right direction.
- I think it has too overall.
Coming down to, especially
coming down to how we're
internally feeling, and that's what I
tried to encompass with my last album,
Apologies in Advance.
What we try to encompass with our label
and our company, Wise Up.
It's really sparking the conversation
so that we can change and
also alter perspective.
- You should put out more
content that isn't music.
- [Sylvan] Yeah, I agree.
I think that is the
gateway to your unlock.
If I had music talent
and put out an album,
it would do real well.
- [Amir] You've got a nice audience.
- I think not knowing
how you create music,
a lot of times, you guys know this I know,
I'm always like more music, more music,
mainly 'cause that's one's outlet.
I think just the general
thoughtfulness of your demeanor,
I think you should do more of what I do.
I think you should do a
30 minute call in show
where people just call in and
ask you questions like I do.
- [Sylvan] Wow.
- Yeah, I just think
that you're interested
and vibed towards other things
that I think are important,
in the same way that if you
look at the genre of hip hop,
people are just hip hop
artists, and then they became
culturally relevant individuals,
business men and women.
I just think that you have white space to
have a different conversation
with your audience.
- [Amir] Agreed.
So now you've got some homework.
- [Sylvan] Pretty much so.
- You know?
I just think it would be interesting
to see if you went there.
- I think he should.
I mean he had put an email address
in his profile on Twitter,
and he's like, "Hey, if you're
going through some shit,
"send me an email."
And he legit was going
through all those emails.
So I mean, but being able to do that.
I think it's sincere.
- I used to do that, 2007,
2011, that's all I did.
And then I've made it more outwardly
because what I realized is cool
I can answer that kid's question
or that grown up's question,
but it was a one to one thing,
meanwhile 30% of my audience
was dealing with the same shit.
- I like the call in idea a lot, though.
I think that's dope.
And I think it will be impactful
because he's sincere and genuine.
- And I also think it's good
content, it's good content.
You put that on YouTube,
you put it in a podcast,
you put it on Facebook and Instagram,
and you know, you're just
building an authentic,
all it comes down to is relationships.
And there's a lot of ways
to have relationships.
I just really, I feel
like I'm going through
with my business content
and personal content
something very similar to
putting out a hit album
that reached people.
- [Sylvan] That's very true.
- And those 300 people
that came to the show,
it wasn't a normal 300.
The videos I've seen, the crowd was going,
you go so deep with your fans,
'cause you're putting your heart into it.
You're going so much deeper
than a lot of artists.
- So what's happening now?
- Right now, we're post
Apologies in Advance,
so we've been releasing records,
working on another record
that's slated for some
time later this year.
Don't want to spill on that aspect.
Possibly planning another tour.
- Do you write?
- I write everything.
- And what is, do you just like,
if it randomly hits you
you just start writing
or you have a set regiment or?
- What's funny is I
usually write all the time.
- [Gary] You're always writing.
- Yeah, I'm always writing.
Usually when I'm creating records
I usually create the record first.
So I'll start by producing.
I also produce all of my content.
So my last album was
entirely produced by myself.
And I'll just start writing,
and then we'll create the actual message
and formula around it as we're getting
halfway into the album.
Every album I do, everybody work I have
has to come with something
you can do take away and use.
It has to.
That's my brand.
That's what Wise Up stands for.
It's changing perspectives
and opening conversation.
So that comes first.
And then the music comes.
The music is just the platform for--
- I really, really think
you would do Q&A, man.
My point of view, I took
a very different turn
once I really made it
about them even more.
I got all sorts of things
going through my head,
and I'm real quiet with myself
and I have unlimited content,
but when you're answering questions,
when you're answering three
or four questions a day,
five, seven, nine, three, 16,
you're in listening mode,
and you have a different level,
I have such a different level
of pulse than everybody,
because I'm listening.
People just see the output of me talking.
They don't see my 24 hours.
Right?
They see me interviewing somebody.
Gary you're always talking,
you're always talking.
I'm like, no, no, I'm always
talking when you're seeing me.
My other 16 hours a day are me listening.
- Wow.
- Internalizing, reflecting,
and then they're only seeing the output.
- People always want to engage in--
- You just gotta have a better pulse.
- Pretty much so.
- It's things you couldn't even imagine.
It's a kid calling in
telling you they're stuck on a drug
because they're really just anxious,
and then using a terminology to a drug
you've never heard before.
Just a slang term.
I don't know what else to say.
- No, that's dope.
I think it's good to
know what's out there.
I'm a little bit older,
but when I met somebody like Mike Boyd,
God knows how many years ago,
I was like shit, he really knows
what the fuck is happening.
He's paying attention.
All these artists--
- Ear to the street, right?
- Yeah, ear to the street.
And I'm like, okay cool,
what's hiphop.lunch.com,
I'm like, what, I haven't heard of--
- Half these people.
- Half of these people,
but I'm going to all
these other sites who I won't name
who were like, cool already saw them,
already saw them, already saw them.
And it's like, yo, wait a minute,
I wanna pay attention
to what you're doing.
You've got your ear to the streets.
And I like that discovery.
Actually no, I love that discovery.
- And it's huge in finding,
that's huge in this world.
I think the closest thing,
the even closer to that
version on the artist's side
is one on one interaction
with the audience.
I gotta bounce.
- Thank you very much.
- It's been a pleasure, man.
I wish you nothing but the best.
- Thank you so much.
- See you, man.
- Absolutely.
- Let me grab a phone number you got.
- Oh sure, most definitely.
- Yeah.
- Thank you again, man.
(mellow music)